تحدثنا قبل قليل عن تعاون السعودي مع عده
دول اسيويه بهدف مكافحه يتغير المناخ ونحن
هنا في جنوب شرق اسيا تايلاند تحديدا في
عاصمتها بانكوك مدينه اثر عليها التغير
المناخي الفيضانات دمرتها قبل عقد من
الزمان وقد تدميرها في المستقبل ايضا يمكن
ان تغمر المياه 40% من بانكوك بحلول 2030
لكن المفارقه تكمن في ان الطبيعه ايضا
يمكن ان تنقذها ولانها مدينه مقتضه
بالسكان
فمهندسها كان لديهم الابتكار او بوادر
الحلول
سنتربايك وسط بانكوك تحارب الفيضانات
لناخذ جوله ونتعرف على الكيفيه الحديقه
مبنيه على منحدر تخزن كميات كبيره من مياه
الامطار والهدف منع الشوارع المحيطات من
الفيضانات
وجه هذه المياه عبر حدائق فرعيه وعبر
اراضي رطبه صناعيه ومن هناك تتدفق الماء
الى بركه للتخزين سعتها
480,000 غالون ولكن
استيعاب ما يقرب من
200,000 جالون
الحديقه بالكامل اي يمكنها ان تخزن ما يصل
الى مليون جالون من المياه نحن نتحدث عن
مؤتمرات تعقد وعلى مستوى كبير لمكافحه
تغير المناخ الذي يهدد العالم
يمكنهم اخذ المثال من بينكوك المناطق
الخضراء
المقاومه للمناخ ولتغير المناخ استثمار
جيد طويل الامد للمدن وافضل الحلول للجيل
القادم